well the Muller report in the end didn't
quite reveal what the left promised it
would spend two years telling us it
would millions and millions of taxpayer
dollars spent thousands of hours of
Investigation and in the end no evidence
of collusion so if you bought in a
hundred percent the idea that the mole
report is could have vindicate all of
your dreams how do you respond well
denial works someone pretending it never
even happened
out in Hollywood a bunch of celebrities
are fully in denial
they say the report actually did expose
collusion and you could discover it too
if you just read all four hundred and
forty eight pages slowly watch the
Russian government attacked our
democracy they interfered in the
presidential election in sweeping and
systematic fashion and made hundreds of
contacts with the Trump campaign all is
a part of a massive covert operation
Vesta Gate connections between Russia
and the Trump campaign Muller delivered
his report on March 22nd and it contains
the most damning evidence ever compiled
against a sitting US president yet
virtually no one has read it and before
the report was even released Trump's
Attorney General William Barr lied about
its content all this is in the report
please just read it for yourself no one
no one not even the President of the
United States is above the law what
percentage of those people move their
lips when they read great voices though
that's for sure Timmy Bruce it's like
Robert De Niro it looks like he just got
out of the shower and was really upset
or something in that imagery the only
thing missing from that tone and the
nature of this was then a discussion
about crop circles and how hieroglyphics
in Egypt on the pyramids were really
communications to the outer space people
look it's pathetic
it's obviously a group of people who are
embarrassed as they should be not just
because of this vid
but because they did tell people for
years that this was going to be the case
and it wasn't just about collusion it
was that the president United States was
a Russian spy I did that but what do you
expect from people who make a living by
living in make-believe and this is it
now the other thing of course the next
video that could follow would be all of
them talking about that the government
still is not arrested the core Leone
family even though we've had three
movies exposing what it is they've done
and then in I'm just a few days ago it's
true you know it just a few days ago we
had a number of senators actually
briefed on UFOs that we know that there
was some briefing about some of the Navy
sightings of lights that they can't
explain and yet decades ago we knew
about Darth Vader and Princess Leia and
Luke Skywalker and we did nothing then
at that point either this is the same
trajectory they're telling people
complete just look at the movie read the
book and you'll believe it too but it's
also insulting Tucker because they're
behaving as though the American people
are even their own constituency other
liberals either are too lazy to read or
read it and didn't understand it
properly or have just given up that they
are the only ones who truly understand
what the dynamic is so so look there's a
lot of rehab for people in Hollywood who
escape reality using drugs and alcohol
there now needs to be one to get them
out of this pathological fixation on
Donald Trump they need to admit they
were wrong and be and get and accept it
which is what most Americans do and move
on so it turns out it must be more
boring than we realize to be an actor
because you'd think if you were a
success if you're Robert De Niro you
think I'm sorry I mean I'm enjoying my
eleven houses in my private plane and
you know the fruits of my labor I'm rich
I'm famous but no he's sitting in some
little studio yelling about Trump into a
camera I don't understand well why the
fixation here's the here's a large part
of the problem you have politicians and
Hollywood who began to believe that they
are the ones that matter that they are
better than everyone else that we're a
bunch of you know deplorable plebs out
here
ruining things and yet we didn't listen
to them in 2016
we rejected their advice we didn't take
them seriously and we still aren't so
for them it's there it's never about
other people for these individuals
because the narcissism is too much and
for them it's about their own a sense of
seriousness their own relevance which of
course it with considering that no one's
taking them seriously it gets gets
battered every single day so this is an
effort to regenerate themselves it has
nothing to do with the country it never
has the irony of course is their
influence is waning I mean their
business is dying exactly being a movie
stars is not what it was even five years
ago